[Applause]
all right chris teague is out here
getting canceled oh boy
what y'all think about this everybody
hates that lady man
you you're a little sanctimonious yeah
like
[ __ ] good words i gotta pretend i
know what that means
i think i do but i don't know i don't
know really either she doesn't
get a little sanctimonious sanctimonious
brother a little sanctity but like
people hate her more than she's bad it
is a little
wild though do you know why she's
getting canceled because she was like
bullying that girl courtney stoddard
a 16 year old she was 25 26 at the time
who was twenty five fifteen chrissy
teigen dm in this girl kill yourself
like
yeah like honestly if you would message
any 16 year old
yeah first yeah you should there should
be a criminal investigation if you're 25
but i don't care gender
explain why the girl was so this girl
was on a reality show i don't remember
which one
she married a 51 year old when she was
16. well i thought he was even older
than that
i think i read 51. double check that
link yeah but
just a super rich guy she was like super
rich lost
what oh he's an actor she need the dude
from lost oh maybe look that up but
basically she's like 16 years old she
marries the dude from laws he's like 51
years old there's a huge age discrepancy
she basically looks like a barbie like
blonde girl
you know super whatever and everybody
went at her which is weird because now
everybody would go at him
well everybody be like yo look at this
old man manipulating this [ __ ]
teenager what that was going on
but everybody [ __ ] on her she's a gold
digger she's this that the
child her mom is a [ __ ] monster to
let it happen exactly
but her mom and the dude are the
monsters she's a 16 year old girl
yeah and even saying like oh we have a
different lens now because social media
is not new to us
yeah it's what i still don't think i'm
talking to a 16 year old
first for any reason yeah especially
kill yourself
yeah like that's wild yeah so so chrissy
teigen is
sorry kill yourself yes and uh because
she doesn't like the fact that she's a
gold digger and she's like making money
i guess off of her body which is
literally what chrissy teigen did for a
living right it's like
you know chrissy wasn't as a model gold
digging off of one person but that's
what modeling is it's just making
money off your looks yeah it's like hey
he's also gonna be fine
say again she's also dealing no deal
second greatest suitcase come up ever
wait was she dealer no deal dealer no
deal oh my god i thought she was
victoria's secret model or something i
think
dealer no deal to swimsuit model to oh
wow
john legend that's sure hey how we got
some [ __ ]
eyes for talent bro america's got talent
real talky that's why he's on it
yeah but yeah so like for her to come
out and just kind of
[ __ ] all over this girl and that way is
a little crazy because she's so woke and
progressive on twitter
yeah and i think that's really why
people are jumping down her throat
because
they're like yo you can't be out here
saying that you know
trump is mean to women and then you out
here bullying this girl worse than
a truck girl it's a teenager bro yeah
wild dude and now if she was never so uh
she was never know so virtuous on
twitter i don't think everybody gives a
[ __ ]
but once you're virtuous on twitter and
you like draw the line in the
because of that yeah and uh i wanted to
defend her because i think you know the
girl lost a kid whatever like i think
all of a sudden we're ganging up on her
now and it's like
but this is even if she wasn't that i'd
be like that's a little wild you're
messaging a 16 year old out of the blue
this is a child yo yeah grow up you
don't need to do that yeah yeah
but you know i realize if you hate trump
a lot if you're an actor it's probably
because you got a little trump in you
you hate what you are you know because
they do the same [ __ ] with super
homophobic people oh you're gay yeah
oh you must be gay you hate homophobic
you're so homophobic must be gay
if you're that traumaphobic you're a
little trump yeah yeah
big trump that's i'm not saying you
gotta love the guy at all but if you
hate him that violently
you're a little trump that's funny like
you see
himself in you because you know that's
why you hate it you know what i would
call messaging a 16 year old to kill
herself what is that deplorable
that's deplorable i would say that's
deplorable behavior deplorable behavior
take a dirt nap that's a deplorable
thing to
take a dirt she tweeted that at her and
then i think she dm'd multiple times
[ __ ] about how she should die
why are you so angry at that i don't
know why are you angry that this girl
manipulated
yeah she didn't have to be feminist like
us like we're big feminists like
progressive feminist men yeah that's who
we are yeah
she don't have to be that but that's
crazy yeah
you know what she said to that teen mom
remember pharah abraham yeah she became
a porn star yeah girl
wow she goes fair abraham now thinks
she's pregnant from her sex tape
in other news you're a [ __ ] and
everyone hates you whoops not other news
sorry
wild that's the name if you make an
unlivable constitution it's going to
eventually like
eat you a lot like you can't make this
these judgments and not have any
sympathy for people yeah
that you can't live up to it's just
unrealistic yeah i didn't understand
what you said until the end
but i think i got it now i know yeah
yeah constitution a set of rules
that you put on other people that you
know where you're gonna have a little
yeah
lock up anyone who does these things and
then you immediately do them and you get
locked up like
you become a prisoner to your own
[ __ ] rules yep
yeah man yeah it's tricky it's tricky
it's tricky it's tricky
i wonder if she has that constitution
or maybe people put that on her what if
she's just a wild girl she's like
you know i just go all feelings no facts
in this [ __ ] and
sometimes people agree with me and they
try to position that as my identity but
the reality is i'm a wild girl and i
[ __ ] on 16 year olds for gold digging as
well
i think she mixes being a wild girl with
being a little sanctimonious
because that's how i always kind of knew
her on twitter as kind of like virtuous
but maybe i came in later i think she'd
be having some funny clapbacks i think
she says funny things on twitter right
but again there is a
there is a streak of like righteousness
to it all
yeah not to all of it but in pockets
it's very like oh i can't believe
somebody would say such a thing and blah
blah blah awful and reprehensible and
yeah that's the thing with righteousness
is that like your righteousness makes a
lot of people feel like [ __ ] sometimes
and if you make me feel like [ __ ] then i
can't wait for your downfall
you know so it's like if righteousness
is tie
i think that's the beauty of like like
being religious
especially christian is it like you get
to be righteous but also say that you're
a failure yeah in your righteousness
like it's baked into the religion it's
like yo i'm a [ __ ] up
just let you know i'm trying to do this
[ __ ] but i'm a [ __ ] up yeah and it's
probably because there was an earlier
iteration of the religion where it's
like i'm perfect and people are like see
no you're not yeah so then they upgraded
and then when it happened you're like no
no i'm a [ __ ] up
oh yeah that's right we're all fuck-ups
it's like there used to be sorry this is
kind of
not as related but you brought up like
the way people used to talk i remember
this old saying to air is human which
it's not from the bible but it's like an
old saying sure i feel like i stopped
hearing that
i used to hear that all the time the air
is human and blah blah blah then
something is divine forgiveness is
divine whatever yeah
you don't hear that anymore ever now to
air you're a piece of [ __ ] you shouldn't
ever exist
[ __ ] you you're canceled yeah and i
think people are enjoying seeing chrissy
teigen get cancelled because it seems
like something she would be okay with
if it happened to other people but
overall it's wild to cancel people
yeah but [ __ ] man messing a 16 year old
is just nuts to me this [ __ ] is just
nuts
i'm sure i said some wild [ __ ] in my day
but i can't imagine messaging a 16 year
old
first yeah like i'ma
go to her profile and click message yeah
what'd she do
just married the dude i think so it
clearly couldn't have been personal she
didn't message chrissy teigen
what did she ruin the ending for lost
like what did she tweeted out the ending
and then like all these people were like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] like i've dedicated
500 hours of my life to this show yeah
and now it's
completely ruined take a dirt nap
if somebody ruined game of thrones for
me before it happened i would have
thanked them
for saving me four years of my [ __ ]
life i mean i understand what you're
saying but also dirty but
but also dirt net lost is the same dirt
that lost apparently people hated the
finale
yeah yeah that's right that's right
that's right it didn't really kind of
wrap the show up
map sounds nice though i don't know dirt
net yeah